welcome back to the rockstars one
division will be the first official
marvel storyline on disney plus the
first marvel phase four story with a
trailer that
resurrects vision pretending like we all
didn't watch thanos given the world's
most painful pimple pop
we're gonna go rogue to discuss how the
hell vision is back
and how wandavision is setting up marvel
phase four because this
is rogue theory the podcast that gives
you the wildest nerdy hot takes on the
topics you can't stop arguing about
i'm eric voss with me today is our
favorite scarlet witch cosplayer
angelica trey
hi hi it's good to be back
good to have you back also with us
comedian and writer jessica clemens
welcome back
hi dad hi
oh boy um this is my family
i feel at home we're brady bunch in it
yeah
we are we totally are uh and finally
first time here on new rockstars
a guy who definitely gets the daily
struggle of
gunten on youtube from the amazing
channel
everything always michael roman welcome
michael
what's up all thanks for having me eric
so glad to have you here i really
do feel like i have assembled the dream
team of people i want to talk about one
division with
all three of you i expect very hot
takes from because this episode we are
only going to be talking about
wandavision
because we know many of you out there
found this trailer confusing as hell
hell being the operative word as i
speculated in my trailer breakdown go
check that out if you haven't seen it
yet
but the first question i think we want
to explore is
how vision is back from the dead there
are
really a few plausible ways i could see
this series justifying his resurrection
but
i want to know from you three how is
vision back
michael why don't you go first i'm
thinking there's a good chance that
maybe wanda
willingly or unwillingly made a deal
with someone
maybe mephisto or some other demonic
magic that has that play here and has
brought him back from the dead
and uh i think some other fans of dr
strange the original film
will notice what was missing was uh
visions and symbols of the occult
this would be a great way to work them
in and then bring them back in the
second doctor strange
oh very interesting so are you saying
that um
you said wittingly or unwittingly let's
explore both those options so like
wittingly
uh is this something she's doing
independently that maybe mephisto and
agatha
are recognizing and jumping on that
train or is it something that like she
has accidentally sucked in
this nosy neighbor agatha well i think
there's
a lot to be gained from her power set
being on your side if you have ill
intentions right someone like mephisto
who's maybe been sitting on the sideline
waiting seeing what's going down
all of a sudden you see a vulnerable
wanda and you can take advantage of that
and if you're able to manipulate her
either with agatha or not
depending on what's going on there then
i think there's a lot of
purpose in it and there's a lot to be
gained from having her on your side so
unwittingly if she doesn't recognize the
manipulation but hey she has a lot to
gain too
she lost vision in the rest of her
family she just wants it back at all
costs so
yeah i i think the biggest thing i'm
still scratching my head over is
how these episodes will um find their
way into this whole
angle like uh are they gonna start are
they going to dive in the deep end and
we just
open the series on the way the trailer
did in the middle of this 50s reality
or is it going to be like we start with
heartbroken wanda
unable to get sleep at night because she
misses vision so much and then like she
knocks on her neighbors next door and
it's catherine han
and she's like hey i have a spell book
that can help you out or does
she like start in the middle of like
fractured reality and agatha's like
you know in her weird you know ouija
board seance is like
i think we can take advantage of this
ex-avenger master and
yeah i'm just kind of curious what
exactly that first episode's going to be
it's going to be interesting to see and
of course
they risk giving up the ruse if they
show us how she got in there in the
first place so
most likely we're not going to find out
until the whole thing turns right
yeah i know i know i just want the ruse
right now
i don't want to have to protect them
trailers um but i do love it they're
leaving it a mystery agreed
agreed um and uh for going this whole
angle of uh wanda sorcery
um we're gonna uh decide our judge this
week decide who gets points for this
will be our friend from an alternate
universe
mr meeseeks look at me um
how many points do you think michael
deserves to that one oh existence is
pain why did you just apparate me to
make me give points because it's a
never-ending process
uh two points two points thanks mr me
sakes
so uh next up let's let's explore a
different angle of how vision could be
back jessica what do you think
congratulations on your emmy rick and
morty so
i think uh going off that uh i think
that
vision is gonna be revived uh through
wakanda and stark technology with the
help of shuri
so shuri was able or almost able to take
out the stone
from vision's head um take the stone
from the dog
if you will and i think that
we all know now that like i think her
and tony stark are equally just as
intelligent but i think now that stark
is gone
arguably sure he's the most smartest
person in the mcu a lot
like smartest human in the mcu along
with bruce banner but her being the
smarter one
either way i think that uh swords gonna
come to shuri and be like hey i need you
to revive the
one of the strongest people that we need
to come back to the normal realm because
wanda's going crazy uh she's having a
hard time she's having a breakdown and i
completely understand we're all living
that 20 20 life
um if i had wanda's powers i'd go crazy
too
but i think since she's having her
meltdown they're going to enlist
shuri to kind of revive what was the
remnants
of vision because we didn't really see
his body we don't know where he went
so i think when she brings him back
sword is going to be in charge of making
sure he goes back into that universe
where wanda is going crazy
and hopefully calm her down and that's
how we're going to see monica she's
gonna be working for sword and she's
gonna be the handler like the liaison
for agent
uh or for the agent for sword and for
vision so she's always monitoring
closely and also letting sword know
from the inside what the hell is going
on because no one really knows
in the trailer we see her like getting
shot out of this like bubble
yeah and she's like it's so quick but
it's obvious that it's like
handled like um like uh the mist
this is a really bad analogy but like
the myth no the mystic is never a bad
analogy the myst is amazing
it's a good movie uh it's a good good
movie so like how in the midst how they
are aware of this rip in this world
um i think that's how wanda's gonna be
she's gonna be
she's gonna make another universe
there's alternate universes we all know
that from the spider verse
but i think she's gonna make a hole in
this different universe and it's
monitored outside
by sword and other intelligence and i
think that's where like
they keep sending monica in and out
that's such an interesting take very
well thought out jessica uh
and i love this idea of picking up this
loose thread of how
much of vision did shuri detach from the
mind stone
and i love that idea of like some
version of his consciousness could be
downloaded black
mirror style uh into the wakanda servers
well they said and they said an end game
they were like bruce was when they're in
that room
that room bruce was like we keep saying
that his stone is him but he is still
a vision behind the stone yeah you could
take out the stone and we still have all
the technology that we put in there but
also his exact
beam so i think that's still possible i
don't think bruce banner is completely
wrong
yeah the the infinity war contingency
plan
could still absolutely and i also love
this idea i've just been assuming that
vision is part of wanda's
um illusion reality warping but like
he clearly is a point of view character
in this like he's as confused as
everyone else is he's not just like
a recording of something so this idea of
he
is another agent that maybe sword have
uh implanted in the
in there the way they did monica is i
could totally see that uh
being true um but mr meeseeks what do
you think
i think it's worth three rogy points
please kill me not yet we have another
half hour so well done
um all right angelico how do you think
vision has come back into the mcu
okay so i'm thinking wanda created a
pocket universe where vision is still
alive
even though it's threatening our reality
okay
so we saw in infinity war that wanda and
vision clearly have this like mind
connection right
so what if when vision died one actually
absorbed some of his consciousness and
she was so grief-stricken that she made
this entire pocket universe
use that consciousness to resurrect him
and because
it's most likely threatening the reality
perhaps maybe wanda's being guided by
somebody
with her growing powers like i don't
know agatha harkness
and she is essentially turning this
tv series like um pocket universe into
a full-fledged alternate reality where
she still has
vision i i love that and i love that
using the term pocket universe or pocket
reality because i feel like that's gonna
be
our shorthand for this whenever we try
to explain it it's like
baby yoda yeah we just kind of came with
the word baby yoda cause the only way we
could explain it
it's like yeah it's a pocket universe a
polly pocket universe you open it you
close it
she bounces around she gets to be in the
living room here she gets
this is a guy who's making me a deli
sandwich as he's explaining to me who on
the vision is yeah
just take universe and then put put
something in front of it pocket
we could try to do miniverse but i don't
know if that quite works like pocket
feels separate
and like its own entity and i think
wanda has
the ability and the powers to do this
and build this sort of thing
yeah and pocket is the ultimate thing
things get lost in pockets there are
holes in pockets
uh you know peter pocket peter pocket
all the kind eric over here yeah the
connotation works they should have just
told us it's called a pocket universe
perfect metaphor exactly um and i do
love this idea of going back to the
connection between
uh wanda maximoff and vision because
clearly that is very important those
moments at the beginning of infinity war
where they remind us that like the mind
stone is where her
powers were derived at least in the mcu
they may
retcon a little bit of that maybe
they'll go back now that they have
access to
the mutant mythology in the in the mcu
uh they might say like oh she's from
magneto or
chauthon you know the demon blessed her
as a baby
we'll see how deep into that they go but
um yeah that mind stone connection i
think will be very very important i
think it's worth noting that in these uh
one division trailer footage shots
he has the mind stone in his head once
more despite it being destroyed so
i think that connection is is right what
do you think mr mistakes
i think that's worth it two rogies
i hate this yeah i'm regretting this
decision
i'm i'm already traumatized so i'm just
going with the flow at this point i'll
deal with the trauma later
take the rookies now deal with it later
that's right that's right
um when we solve rogies
if you want if you want i've just been
assigning points i forgot to see what
the conversion was
i guess i don't really care about that
converted into a starfleet symbol
yeah it did nice
we want to thank our friends from gabby
insurance for helping us make this
episode
when you have had the same car insurance
or homeowners insurance for years you
kind of get
trapped into paying your premiums and
really not thinking about it
that makes it really easy to overpay and
not even realize you're doing it i've
had the same old insurance
for ages on autopay it's kind of like a
drawer in my fridge that i'm afraid to
check for fear that those old carrots
have
turned alive uh well you don't want that
to happen
you need to stop overpaying for car and
homeowners insurance
see about getting a lower rate for the
exact same coverage you already have
thanks to gabby gabby takes the pain out
of shopping for insurance by giving you
an apples to apples comparison for your
current coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive
nationwide and travelers just link your
current insurance account
and in just minutes you'll be able to
see quotes for the exact same coverage
you currently have
that's what i did and actually off
screen producer zack used gabby to look
for new car insurance and found a policy
that was almost 200 a year cheaper than
the one he had
in just a few minutes of looking gabby
customers save 825
per year on average if they can't find
you savings like they did for us
they'll let you know so that you can
relax knowing that you had the best rate
out there
and they'll never sell your info so no
annoying spam no robocalls
it's totally free to check your rate and
there's no obligation
just take a few minutes right now and
stop overpaying on your car and home
insurance
go to gabby.com theory that's g
a b i dot com slash theory
gabby dot com theory and we also want to
thank our good friends at
manscape for sponsoring this episode do
you have a moose near the caboose that
needs to be tamed
i am talking hairy big and needs some
support
well thankfully our sponsor today
manscaped has you covered
to keep the hair looking nice and
trimmed and feeling fully
supported manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
we here at new rockstars love our
friends at manscaped we love getting to
make ridiculous puns during the ads
and we especially love their products
which keep us feeling good
and looking good without injuring
ourselves the manscaped engineering team
just perfected
the greatest ball hair trimmer ever
created the lawnmower
3.0 the premium lawnmower 3.0 is
waterproof it includes an
led light and is made with advanced
skin safe technology which reduces the
nicks and cuts on your delicates
you can get this trimmer inside their
perfect package 3.0
which includes the manscaped crop
preserver ball deodorant and
crop reviver ball toning spray super
practical
and they smell great too plus for a
limited time when you order the perfect
package kit
you get two free gifts the shed travel
bag and the manscaped anti-chafing
boxer briefs the manscape boxer briefs
have optimal temperature control with
their crop coolant technology
pair these box of reefs with their ph
balancing liquid products like the crop
preserver and you're ready for
anything that requires your nut hairs to
not exist you need to try this out for
yourself get 20
off and free shipping with the code
rogue theory
at manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping
at manscaped.com and use the code rogue
theory
from the moose to the caboose always use
the right tools for the job
and every week we play a game of rogue
theory with our patrons on the new
rockstars discord server this week we
had patrons pitch theories about the
upcoming second season of the
mandalorian and how our favorite mando
is going to betray his ward
baby yoda we've had some fun theories
from the pog dog
in taskmaster 69 but the winner
was gold komodo with their theory that
mando will get manipulated by moth
gideon into believing it's the
jedi that have evil intentions for baby
yoda allowing him to abscond
with the child interesting stuff there
because i i believe and i agree that the
jedi
do kind of have messed up intentions
as well i think that's one thing we we
learned from the prequels and the uh
and the animated series that um the jedi
are kind of screwed up they're occult
but you can play discord rogue 32 by
becoming a patron of new rockstars and
joining our
discord but now we return to the many
questions we have
for wanda vision on disney plus as we've
already mentioned the new one division
trailer gave us their first glimpses of
some of the actors we knew were going to
be in the series including catherine
hahn and tiana paris
we also know that randall parks went
back as jimmy wu kat dennings is going
back as darcy lewis but there was one
previously announced actor who was not
in the trailer that has us especially
intrigued
evan peters you'll know evan peters he
played quick silver from the
fox x-men movies he was also an american
horror story
he's going to be playing some role in
wanda vision we've made a couple videos
speculating on who he's going to be but
i want to know from you three
who do you think evan peters is going to
be in one division and why do you think
he wasn't in this trailer angelica let's
start with you this time
okay evan peters is going to play
mephisto nice yeah okay okay
so let me just backtrack a little bit
here but
i think he would make such a good
villain that why not play
the prince of darkness himself plus
not only that but it could carry over to
other properties like doctor strange 2
and blade yeah just wreaking havoc
yeah everyone keeps talking about evan
peters as uh as
quick silver um but i everyone overlooks
the fact that he was an american horror
story and i believe had
so many more interesting roles as this
really really dark
figure i think he'd be an amazing
mephisto in the mcu and
i want a younger mephisto i don't need
like kind of an old
uh you know pacino satan
i i want i want a little boy satan
because i feel like that's the devil
you think didn't exist right i don't
know sure
i don't know where i'm going i don't
know either no he would he would make a
great mephisto
and a great prince of darkness like he's
he's got something about him that he
could do
a lot more just beyond quicksilver in
terms of being
evil like i i know it i feel it evan
peters
we're watching you yeah that said his
quicksilver was really fun so if
either of you other two are bringing up
quicksilver don't be ashamed but what do
you think mr me sings no one will wait
you get one do i show you okay
sure i don't know thank you wow
so cute wow all right jessica who do you
think evan peters is playing
so you guys were all talking about it so
i gotta bring it up
i think he's coming back as quicksilver
now hear me out
hear me out after hearing you talk about
that
possibly uh wanda is just imagining
that um that vision's there what if in
all these series of old-timey tv
tv tropes he plays like her dead brother
but comes back
and he's in her visions so oh
inside it's inside visions and visions
so
mind-blown mind-blown um uh
also sidenote edited out a great porn
title for a knockoff version of this
vision and vision whatever way we're
keeping that in mind
that's enough opening seconds of the
video first off i'm probably gonna get
sued because it's probably already been
made
just intro right into that it's the
first thing they hear
genius so what if okay so what if
her uh if quicksilver comes back within
those visions
or whatever she's creating in this
pocket universe
and it's still we need to remember that
it's still
disney so it's still gonna have its sad
moments and i feel like
her envisioning that its vision is a
great idea for like an
already like climaxing sad moment but to
have her
like have quicksilver come back in it
and play like a hey i'm the brother and
she's just like
wait a minute are you my brother like
what's going on here
i think would be a really good addition
into like that madness that she's been
eating into
and yes of course there's a new
quicksilver we all know there's a new
one
but we also know that they're known to
replace people
like don cheadle and terence howard and
then even in dc where they had an
episode with both flashes in it
there's uh there's multiple things that
they can do and they don't mind
changing it up a little bit so i think
he will come back as quicksilver it's
also his f everybody loves quicksilver
it's very fun for him to play we all
want it again
he was the best thing from those movies
i think he was um
yeah that's fair and anything's possible
in the mcu
like especially within wanda vision
because
wanda has these mind-bending reality
bending powers so
actually i like that it just could be a
quick simple way to bring in anybody
from the fox x-men movies that they want
to have
existing mcu uh deadpool you know
fassbender mcavoy anybody else they
would want
um what do you think mr meeseeks also
won
oh you get one point this mason jar
with some remnants of cold brew oh
no no thank you all right uh michael who
do you think evan peters is playing
okay well i think those were two really
good answers uh but there's a chance
he could be playing speed one of wanda's
two kids now
i might have to play devil's advocate
see i got puns too devil's advocacy with
a devil's uh
yeah so it could be the fact that he's a
little bit older than elizabeth olsen
which would be weird because it's her
son but we also know in the spock of
reality that they could age at any speed
so that's really not a big deal
the second weird thing would about this
would be the fact that he's already
played quicksilver
and now he's playing speed it's like
really do we not have enough actors in
hollywood you gotta just cast this one
guys the fast man for everybody
like the way that maisie williams was
technically how stark
who was a warg and then immediately
played wolf's bane who could
yeah where you could only play wolf
characters or speed yeah maybe maybe
maybe we should get the agent to read
some other scripts you know sort of
branch out but either way
uh there's a chance he could be doing
that and you know look
he is the best thing i totally agree
with you eric he's the best thing out of
those x-men movies those scenes are
awesome
yeah hey there's there's a chance he
could be playing speed music what do you
think
also won um mr music has become kind of
an egalitarian in this round
uh all right so that brings you to one
point
we're now going to move on to our final
round of rogue
questions so i'm looking for some quick
quick punchy answers on this one
uh funniest get some points so here we
go question one
disney has announced that starting
october it will have mando
mondays which are weekly merch releases
for the mandalorian
now that mondays are taken what's
another property that should move
quickly to claim a different day of the
week okay well anyone that knows me is
probably screaming right now
but trekkie tuesday i don't know oh sure
yeah i love a good day just dedicated to
trek trek is love trek is life
trek is life trek is life trek is
completely life well i got one for you
how much do you guys miss frasier
a lot okay so what about what about
frasier fridays
bring back the original cast it's the
most under appreciated shared universe
the cheers frasier universe i need more
niles crane i'm gonna go with frasier
fridays
yeah we had fraser um in a weekly sitcom
for what like
14 years or something crazy like he was
uh
he had back-to-back runs he didn't
you're right there is a crazy tommy
westfall cinematic universe there
let's let's stay topical you know let's
stay on board with the youth
um and we we're the youth are asking for
for a whop for a wet ass pixar and
we'll play that on wednesdays and it's
called what ass pixar because
we all cry at pixar films so that
wednesday you get a bowl of popcorn
bravo with your family and you
cry and you get emotional and you walk
okay that is not where i thought you
were going okay
not i mean whatever y'all want
i thought you were going elastigirl for
that one i mean that's where everyone
else goes
i'm sure everyone was like i am told
wait never mind i'm not gonna mention
the lamp i'm just kidding
well mr mesix loves animation so
one rogie
and our final question the emmys
happened on sunday one of our favorites
hbo's watchmen
won a ton of awards i would like you
to give your acceptance speech for your
performance on this episode of rogue
theory
[Music]
so um thank you everyone that's here
brad pitt in the front row christian
bale in the third
um i think that i deserve to be on this
show
and it was great that i was allowed to
be on this show again
i had a lot of fun wanda vision means a
lot to me disney plus i pay for you
monthly and i work for you
so um i just want to say thank you to my
mom
to god to uh zendaya for winning
winning an emmy um and to all my fans
out there
um this is for all of you in the streets
not watching this because you're on the
streets no no wait a minute oh wait
oh god i forgot we don't have laptops on
the streets
how are the there's no internet there
hey there's that sweet mcdonald's wi-fi
okay
oh there is um all right uh
is this and this is my trophy okay
okay oh my oh my god this is
um so unexpected i'm so nervous totally
did not expect to win
a whole emmy for this i first of all
would just like to thank everybody for
recording coordinating this
um especially zack uh eric thank you so
much
for you know making sure that i don't
ramble for too long
and all my puns don't get too cringy
just kidding they're pretty cringey
and um a huge thank you to
the editors for making sure that they
censor all of my swears
with kitten meows because um i swear
like a mother
freaking thank you guys so much and um
totally again unexpected i uh
i would first like to thank new
rockstars for having given me this
opportunity
uh this is my i got my rocket here i
just like to use
this opportunity to bring up raccoon
awareness uh they're your friends
you know they just want to get in on the
action and if it was delicious for you
okay it was delicious for them i just
want you to remember that
and uh you know love you love your local
trash panda
absolutely and the music has played him
off
and he goes the wrong way and then the
escort has to tell him to go the other
way
are they called escorts what are they
called the people who have the trophy
i i just assumed they were sports but i
don't think that's the right word yeah
they're interns
they're not but they get to hold the
trophy
yes they do well the winner of this week
of rogue theory is
jessica glemmons whoa
there he goes congratulations jessica do
you have a wish
that we can fulfill for you um i would
love to hear
everyone's uh mr meeseek's impression
before we go
i think you've heard enough of mine nope
i want to hear some more
oh jeez rick i don't know oh geez rick
that's just morning
that's a great wish just give me what i
didn't want you know going off of
michael's and trying to do like a
a a rick impression
morty stick away
that was good that was the greatest so
yeah as for mr meeseeks you got all of
justin roiling's character i got a
variety i got
more bang from a book i would expect
nothing less from this group no doubt
yep we did it guys that's it for this
episode of rogue theory
thank you to all of our guests angelica
trey thank you guys so much for having
me it's always great to be back on
and make sure to follow over on twitch
atrey also twitter hra
instagram angelica tray thank you guys
yeah as well as uh jessica clemens thank
you for coming back
of course um you can just follow me on
lulu clemens on everything social media
and also
uh collegehumors dropout show game
changer season three just dropped today
and i'm on one episode where you learn
too much about my history and i
shouldn't have disclosed so much
we're watching it please don't if you do
just don't come look for me ever again
i'm gonna be in a cave
[Laughter]
uh and michael thank you so much uh for
for joining us today it was so great to
have you on the show eric i really
appreciate it man dream come true you
guys can find me of course on everything
always i also stream on twitch under
novella and i have original music on
spotify
under all fires i just couldn't use the
same branding for everything that would
have made it easy so
wherever but thank you guys so much for
having me i appreciate it man
yeah definitely uh check out everything
always lots lots of great stuff if you
like new rockstars you'll definitely
like that channel as well
uh and you can uh subscribe to the rogue
theory podcast feed wherever you get
your podcasts
uh subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and make sure to subscribe to
our
other uh social channels follow me on
instagram and twitter at
eavos and uh we'll see everyone next
week bye bye
bye guys
[Music]
you